[Musik]
der code ich übergebe die waffe mit der
nummer golf giulia 286 griff seinen
auftritt und im vergleich zu dem was
irgendwo mal beim bundesheer bei einer
ausstellung sekt und torte seghers und
dann mal silber und andere diese
scheidung unterschied ungewohnt aber das
würde ja der safe zeit haben wir als
stromberg wenn man das ganze zeug
klangkörpern neues zum putzen hund und
wir sind einverstanden sind den grünen
haben beim rest lässt fast immer
versperren oder am man verstanden ist
ein quatsch betroffen oder irgendwas
jetzt auch was noch auf die zeitnahme
flaschen reich okay
[Musik]
doch mal die bürger und den docht alter
begleiter im alltag nur interessante
vorträge vom wirtschafts und tigris
tatsächlich alle gäste wirkten auch
selber die kosten noch einige
komponenten verpflegung
da ist was verschiedenen speisen sondern
mal ein etwas größeres thema zwar
gefragt wissen begibt sich die
vorderseite scheckkartenformat die der
karte wir haben jetzt die com festen
songs steht den ganzen deutschen auf die
tank und den rucksack und mir sagen nach
not kann man das ist das grund ist aber
so konstruiert dass mettlach zum 34
das ist jeder ein hatte vor der hütte
notieren jetzt kleiner kommt bestens
kennt super dann wohl mehr stabilität in
roxel am hüftgurt tamaris trinkflasche
oder montieren und kassierer zeit linken
teams eine bewegung in die fürchten dass
statt sondern die filme leihen und dann
geschlossen
da waren wir nur israel zeige ein hohes
moritz schüler brauchen kunst weil es
der akku schlapp da die schüler zu
erklimmen dafür ist nicht im ausland
haben endspurt nach den seiten her unter
die riemen weile warten
wichtig ist beim rucksack dass die
ganzen bundle mit der vorherigen partie
ist jetzt wurscht aber dass ich zur
armee talanx bahn lobby hinter das ist
bei uns wird
die
[Musik]